good afternoon thanks so much for
joining us at four on this monday i'm
kirsten joyce and i'm christian casadas
you ready we are getting started yes so
we have your live team coverage for you
from the tailgating experience to what's
happening inside the stadium we've got
you covered we begin with kate houston
live outside legion yeah kate vaccines
are required of course to get into the
game this evening
yes that's right and there's a bit of a
line right now now behind me here you
can see the line for alternate screening
this actually wraps around the building
it has grown significantly since it
opened at one o'clock we also have a
line for vaccinations really not as long
but community ambulance expects to
administer a few hundred vaccines today
and they're at a point where they may
need to get more now once inside fans
can get their first or second dose of
the covet 19 vaccine they're offering
moderna and pfizer anyone getting a
vaccine will be considered partially
vaccinated and must wear a mask during
the game now aside from the vaccines
this is also the alternate screening
area now that's for people who are
partially vaccinated those whose vaccine
is not supported by the app those who
are unable to upload their vaccine card
or for those bringing a 12 to 13 year
old that is unable to be added to the
app now thousands utilized this
screening area today and throughout this
entire weekend now this tent will remain
open until seven o'clock fans ages 0 to
11 do not need to go through alternate
screening but fans 2 to 11 do need to
wear a mask during the game reporting
live outside of allegion stadium kate
houston 8 news now